here we are can I tell you this my first
time in Paris and I'm here with you
overlooking Eiffel Tower mission
accomplished
I'm done this is the best but let's say
we have the day and you I know you love
the city if we were to go on a tour
what's the one favorite spot you would
take me a step from the Eiffel Tower one
that's hard this has to be kept not in
this city you cannot I mean not in the
city your favorite croissant please he's
got to go see her side yeah I know you
have to see of course the Louvre
yeah just even walking in the streets I
mean you went for a run this morning and
you know what a great city to get lost
in the trees just along there they're
beautiful parks thanks for having me
thank you for coming is missing isn't it
yeah this is amazing the first question
are you injury-free down here yes yes
you're good healing I'm good
knees good ankles good shoulders good
life is good life is good life is good
you now I can yell at you because you
are insane in this film you took it to
another level I do not expect you to go
I can't wait for everyone to see this
film but you really you take the essence
of being in the zone to a different
level how do you prep or where do you
prep your script your stunts is there a
secret place at home where is just where
Tom goes and does his thing it's you
know it's it's wherever I am really I
kind of I have times that I'm just
resting or relaxing and that's what I'm
kind of thinking about story but also
McHugh and I'll get together the
director Chris McCrory we just we just
have moments were just kicking back and
just talking about story and stuff and
things that we want to do things we want
to explore but prepping these things I
mean this helicopter scene I was
training all over the world from I
trained at Airbus in Texas and then
everywhere I went I had I was training I
was here in Paris as we were shooting
this whole pharisee gets in every day in
the morning and at night I would fly the
helicopter to see and constantly keep
that skill you know razor sharp so you
just do wherever you read right wherever
Africa whatever it is wherever I am sewn
in yeah and I pretty much work seven
days a week
gets there is a reference in the movie
is there water for Tom can we go should
I save him thank you very much you did
it you did it
mission complete again see I could do
that thank you okay yep I'm good
there's a reference in the movie a
guardian angel that's brought up a few
times who is your guardian angel because
you have one if someone's watching over
you who is that person
somebody's watching over me yeah well
you know when I'm doing it it's my stunt
crew yeah Cory yeah because that's one
of the things you're producing these
movies and I it helped to be able to
produce it because it enables us because
I'm the producer also so I'm saying it's
okay that I'm gonna do this but the way
we prep these things I know like I feel
this way when I see and train the other
cast because when they come on I sit
down with them McCrory and I do and say
this is what mission is here's what
you're gonna do and and if you feel like
doing it know I'll train you and we'll
see how your skills are and how far so I
work on their programs to help train
them on a gradient so that it's gonna be
as safe as possible for them and but I
know when they're doing it I'm nervous
when Simon does his stunts doing things
I'm yeah yeah I'm like you know Sammy's
getting thrown around or anything I'm
like yo came in you're getting it you
good just like I got it back off so I
feel I feel very protective you're like
their Guardian name I like their I feel
very protected in them and I know they
feel the same about me that's beautiful
I know they'll be back for mi7 Top Gun
everyone's talking about everyone so
excited I'm gonna take credit for it
because I asked you if you need a need
for speed in Vienna those future because
I'm gonna take care for it but you're a
back you're gonna be a mentor almost
like a father figure 2 miles teller
who's taken on gooses son are you
excited about where you wouldn't we
don't know what the story is you don't
know what the story is it's not that you
don't know what the story is
gonna happen I gotta tell you I can give
me a little bit just give you I'm
thinking you're better for me to have it
yeah okay all right it's called Top Gun
from averin mm-hmm does it be fighter
pilots in it okay
and there's gonna be jets great it's
gonna be a fun story there's gonna be
cool music
yeah and it's you're gonna be a beach
scene there could be a beach scene there
could be a beach scene that's like
that's that's that's all I could tell
you that's all you're still working on
it
don't worry I know you just started with
it I could tell you but then I'd have to
kill you yeah I know I got that we don't
want that to happen or my very good I
know that's why I'm protecting you see
I'm not telling you
so I'm protecting you I didn't work in
my favor we asked fans for a question
for you and one of the questions is that
everyone wants to see you and Dwayne the
rock Johnson work together would you be
open to that concept sure absolutely
yeah be fun it'd be great it would swim
or maybe an action film together that'd
be great fun I love the idea you if you
were to write a book about yourself if
you worry I know you don't have time
what would the title be I don't know you
don't know don't know I have no idea
guardian angel thank you we just keep
going back self proclaimed I don't know
and working with Alec Baldwin it was so
fun seeing you guys together so talented
- yeah he's so great would you ever
consider running for president army
would you ever consider running for
president no no just I love making
movies yeah you know I bought it's all I
want to do my whole life yeah you know
since I was a kid I've really that's
what I wanted to do and you're so good
thank you very much okay thank you
mission possible impossible just have a
few questions
sure mi7 stunts done in Canada
impossible so a my summons happening
possible possible another Jerry Maguire
movie possible impossible impossible yes
how do you see how do you do that again
where do you go I know me you gotta just
play it again what could happen we could
make a story up how could it happen what
do you do how do you do that you can't
hey say the line you complete me right
now possible or impossible you complete
me
you'll be here in Paris again are you
excited about the premiere tonight be
back with your whole casting crew or a
team that's here as well what is this
all me everyone's excited you know it's
20 things we think about talk about we
make the film because we we really
wanted to celebrate Paris it's part of
the you know one of the beauties of
making a mission of my kind of goal is
to be able to go to these different
cultures and celebrate them as we're
making it we think about you know the
audience first and foremost and having
moments like this to be able to go
present it to the city and presented to
the world and you know is there with all
the gang last night the cast and studio
so it's really nice everyone so so damn
excited it's gonna be a beautiful
evening you're arriving on a helicopter
right oh yeah no I'm gonna skydive it
thank you so much so much